[Music]
Brad Pitt is firing back today at his ex
Angelina Jolie the actor had
back-to-back meetings with two separate
attorneys in West Hollywood yesterday
Brad was apparently working on a
response to Angelina's startling claim
made in a public filing yesterday that
he quote has paid no meaningful child
support
since separation this morning Brad's
team filed this response which was
obtained by et in it the actor calls
Ang's no support claimed quote a thinly
veiled effort to manipulate media
coverage he goes to claim that he loaned
Angelina eight million dollars to help
her buy her current home and has paid
over 1.3 million in family bills
Angi spokesperson suggested that Jolie's
filing was just an attempt to move along
the divorce process and quote provide
closure to the marriage and allow her
and Brad to recommit as devoted
co-parent to their children it's a
terrible strategy for a celebrity to
have a divorce going on so publicly
because their brand is damaged in the
process
Christopher Meltzer is a family law
specialist he does not represent either
party these are highly personal
allegations that are being made that
really don't help anyone so what's next
for the couple that met nearly fifteen
years ago on the set of mr. and mrs.
Smith you think the story's gonna have a
happy ending
we're told the situation between them is
tense that Angelina continues to want
sole custody
Brad joint custody and a divorce as
quickly and quietly as possible you hope
at some point they work this thing out
this is all happening by the way while
Angelina and Brad are also in the middle
of making movies Angelina filming
Maleficent - and London while Brad has
been spotted shooting the new Quentin
Tarantino film once upon a time in
Hollywood here in LA
[Music]